[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
concevoir des enfants et les élites et
les baby doll notre nounours est
d'humeur joyeuse ce soir leur fille de
trop se potro va danser nounours nicolas
et pimprenelle seront sûrement très
content et tous nos petits amis aussi
car je suis sûr qu'ils adorent danser
l'eau les vélos ce formidable
alors on va tous t'ont ses ressorts
robben l'homme
pour soir le nom fond qu'est ce que tu a
remué comme ça nous atteint leurs pieds
ferai mes amis ce soir on s'amuse on
entend et on pense le quadrille comment
ça ressemble
nous à les voir vous faites ce que je
vous dit fin mai vous dos et attention
musique boys trop attention mesdames
attention messieurs nous allons danser
un quadrillage de madame pape rhône elle
de ce côté ci quand je dirais que si on
s'incline de roy mange à faire éclater
se relèvera m'attends surtout ne nous
trompons pas c'est la loi
on voit lyon calme en nous un peu écouté
tous les deux mois la jolie qui nous
saluent et maintenant cac de nous
relevons marche lentement en comptant
les pas à deux doigts ne rencontrons
justin planifiait ne nous agrée non un
peu tous les deux
[Musique]
lol lol lol non mais les machines au
salut graciée merci mademoiselle et
parfois déçu enfin une dernière
révérence antilles voilà notre kadri
vous à votre cadre et hawx est drôle tu
ne feras go d'un séminaire sur je vous
le promets à ton avis sacoche et on doit
encore demain demain ou un autre jour je
voulais produit soit de nounours dany ne
le revit dormir tu vois la jette dans la
lumière
[Musique]
ça me ferait plus
où
[Applaudissements]
bonne nuit les petits danseurs
fermez vite vos jolis yeux il est
l'heure de faire de beaux rêves allons
envoûte mettre à danser prend route trop
bonne nuit les enfants à demain otto
bock bonne
[Musique]